i started programming when i was in
eighth grade um in india
and um right at the very early age and
tenth grade i realized the potential for
computer technology to just change the
world
as i was running unified square as ceo
and transitioned to a cto role
um overseeing all technology
i viewed that as a that transition as a
golden opportunity to
reconnect with my undergraduate passion
for ai and its power to change the world
and
um uh professor
ing's um of course
caught my attention right away
being able to have the self-confidence
to tackle very complex ai aspects
especially for someone like me coming in
from a management and leadership role
getting reacquainted with um ai
from very elemental components
for me these programs were a
transformational phase in my life
and marked an inflection point in my
professional and personal life
it marks a moment where i get i could
get reacquainted reconnected in a very
deep and powerful way
uh with my
um uh dream of
deeply innovating in ai in a way that
makes the world a better place and that
makes humanity more effective at what it
does
[Applause]
[Music]
you